encore une fois, un cours difficile,
avait un pourcentage d'échec de 40% à 41%
chaque semestre.
Avec ce cours combiné, à la fin de l'année dernière,
le taux d'échec est tombé à 9%.
Donc les résultats peuvent être extrêmement bons.
Mais avant d'aller trop loin là-dedans,
je voudrais passer un peu de temps à discuter
de certaines idées-clefs.
Quelles sont les idées-clefs
qui font que cela fonctionne ?
Une idée est l'apprentissage actif.
L'idée ici est que plutôt que d'avoir des étudiants
qui arrivent en cours et regardent des cours magistraux,
nous remplaçons cela par ce que nous appelons des leçons.
Les leçons sont des séquences entrelaçées
de vidéos et d'exercices interactifs.
Donc un étudiant peut regarder une vidéo de 5 ou 7min
et faire suivre cela avec un exercice interactif.
Imaginez cela comme l'ultime Socratisation de l'éducation.
Vous enseignez en posant des questions.
Et c'est une forme d'apprentissage
appelée apprentissage actif,
qui a été promue très tôt dans un article de 1972
par Craik et Lockhart,
dans lequel ils disaient et découvraient
que l'apprentissage et la rétention sont réellement liés
à la profondeur du procédé mental.
Les étudiants apprennent bien mieux
quand ils interagissent avec le sujet.
La deuxième idée est d'aller à son rythme.
Quand j'allais en cours magistral,
et si vous étiez comme moi,
après 5 minutes, je perdais le rythme.
Je n'étais pas si intelligent, et je prenais des notes
et je perdais le rythme du cours pour le reste de l'heure.
A la place, est-ce qu'il ne serait pas mieux d'utiliser des technologies en ligne,
d'offrir des vidéos et des engagement interactifs aux étudiants ?
Ils peuvent mettre sur pause.
Ils peuvent revenir en arrière.
Ils peuvent même mettre le professeur sur silence !
Donc cette possibilité d'aller à son rythme
peut vraiment aider l'apprentissage.
La troisième idée est que nous n'avons pas assez de retours.
Avec des retours immédiats,
les ordinateurs notent les exercices.
Comment faire autrement pour noter 150 000 étudiants ?
Votre ordinateur note tous les exercices.
Et nous avons tous rendu des devoirs,
et votre note vous revient deux semaines plus tard,
vous l'aviez même oublié.
Je ne pense pas que j'ai même récupéré tous mes devoirs
de mes années d'université.
Certains ne sont jamais notés.
Alors avec un retour immédiat,
les étudiants peuvent essayer d'appliquer les réponses.
S'ils ont faux, ils peuvent recevoir un retour immédiat.
Ils peuvent essayer encore et encore,
et cela devient vraiment beaucoup plus engageant.
Ils obtiennent ces retours immédiats,
et cette petite coche verte que vous voyez ici
est un peu devenue un symbole culte à edX.
Les étudiants nous disent qu'ils vont se coucher
en rêvant de cette coche verte.
En fait, un de nos étudiants
qui a suivi le cours sur les circuits l'année dernière,
a ensuite suivi un cours sur les logiciels
à l'Université de Berkeley à la fin de l'année,
et voici ce que cet étudiant a dit
sur cette petite coche verte
lors de notre forum de discussion
alors qu'il avait juste commencé le cours
« Mon dieu, tu m'as manquée ! »
A quand remonte la dernière fois où les étudiants
ont eu des commentaires comme ça sur les devoirs ?
Mon collègue Ed Bertschinger
qui est à la tête du département de physique au MIT,
a dit cela à propos des retours inmmédiats :
Il dit que les retours immédiats
transforment les moments d'enseignement en résultats d'apprentissage.
La prochaine grande idée est la gamification.
Vous savez, tous les étudiants aiment vraiment
les vidéos interactives, etc...
Vous savez, ils pourraient s'asseoir et
tirer sur des vaisseaux aliens toute la journée jusqu'à ce qu'ils y arrivent.
Donc nous appliquons ces techniques de gamification à l'apprentissage
et nous pouvons construire ces laboratoires en ligne.
Comment enseignez-vous la créativité ? Comment enseignez-vous le design ?
Nous pouvons faire cela à travers des laboratoires en ligne
et utiliser le potentiel des ordinateurs
pour construire ces laboratoires en ligne.
Donc comme cette petite vidéo vous le montre ici,
vous pouvez faire travailler les étudiants
comme s'ils faisaient du design avec des Legos.
Donc ici, les étudiants construisent un circuit
aussi facilement que s'ils jouaient avec des legos.
Et ça aussi peut être noté par un ordinateur.
La cinquième idée est l'apprentissage avec ses pairs.
Donc ici, nous utilisons des forums de discussions
et des interactions comme sur Facebook
non pas comme un distraction
mais pour vraiment aider les étudiants à apprendre.
Laissez-moi vous raconter une histoire.
Quand nous avons prévu de faire notre cours sur les circuits
pour les 155 000 étudiants,
je n'ai pas dormi pendant les 3 jours
précédant le début du cours.
J'ai dit à mes assistants : « Ok, 24h sur 24, 7 jours sur 7,
nous allons être debout
à monitorer le forum et à répondre aux questions. »
Ils avaient répondu aux questions de 100 étudiants.
Comment voulez-vous le faire pour 150 000 ?
Donc une nuit, j'étais assis là, à 2h du matin,
et je réfléchissais à la question
d'un étudiant du Pakistan.
Il a posé une question, et j'ai dit :
« Ok, laisse-moi un peu de temps pour taper la réponse,
je ne tape pas aussi vite, »
et j'ai commencé à taper la réponse.
Et avant que j'aie eu le temps de finir,
un autre étudiant d'Egypte est arrivé avec une réponse,
pas complètement juste, donc j'ai commencé à corriger la réponse,
et avant que j'aie eu le temps de finir, un étudiant des Etats-Unis
est arrivé avec une réponse différente.
Je me suis alors assis et j'ai regardé, fasciné.
Boom, boom, boom, boom, les étudiants
étaient en train de discuter et d'interagir les uns avec les autres.
Et à 4h du matin, j'étais complètement fasciné,
c'était une révélation,
et à 4h du matin,
ils avaient trouvé la bonne réponse.
Et tout ce que j'avais à faire, c'était de venir et de la bénir :
« Bonne réponse. »
Donc c'est absolument incroyable
quand les étudiants apprennent les uns des autres,
et ils nous disent qu'ils apprennent
en enseignant.
Maintenant, ça n'arrive pas seulement dans le futur.
Ça arrive aujourd'hui.
Donc nous appliquons ces pilotes d'apprentissage combinés
dans un certain nombre d'universités et de lycées autour du monde,
depuis Tsinghua en Chine
jusqu'à la National University of Mongolia en Mongolie
en passant par Berkeley en Californie --
tout autour du monde.
Et ces différents genres de technologies aident vraiment,
le modèle combiné peut réellement aider
à révolutionner l'éducation.
Il peut résoudre un problème pratique des MOOC,
l'aspect business.
Nous pouvons aussi donner une licence pour ces cours MOOC
à d'autres universités,
et là se trouve un modèle de revenu pour les MOOC
lorsque l'université accorde une licence au professeur
qui peut utiliser ces cours en ligne
comme le manuel scolaire de la prochaine génération.
Ils peuvent les utiliser autant qu'ils le veulent,
et cela devient un outil dans l'arsenal du professeur.
FInalement, je voudrais que
vous rêviez pour moi un instant.
Je voudrais que nous ré-imaginions vraiment l'éducation.
Nous devrons passer du cours magistral à l'espace internet.
Nous devrons passer des livres aux tablettes
comme les Aakash en Inde
ou les Raspberry Pi à 20 dollars.
L'Aakash vaut 40 dollars.
Nous devons passer de l'école bâtiment
aux dortoirs numériques.
Mais je pense qu'au final,
je pense que nous devrons encore avoir des cours magistraux
dans nos universités.
Autrement, comment dirons-nous à nos petits-enfants
que leur grands-parents s'asseyaient dans ces salles